l'image d'un d'un peuple uni derrière
son président c'est que c'est un réflexe
naturel un peu d'être légitimiste
entendent eux en temps de guerre il a
l'air d'être particulièrement marqué
quand même en ce moment en ukraine avec
cette guerre contre la russie alors
après les raisons bon c'est d'abord
c'est assez classique quand il ya une
agression comme ça aussi soudaine
qu'inattendue même si on en parlait
beaucoup enfin puisque vous avez dit en
fait c'étaient les américains qui
parlait beaucoup d' invasion imminente
je vous rappelle que les les européens
eux et le président hélène ce qui lui
même d'ailleurs trouvé que les
américains étaient trop alors vous êtes
trop donc quand ça arrive ya un effet de
sidération
puis un effet de 2,2 de tristesse de
désarroi et puis après souvent très vite
à un effet de colère de grande colère et
puis on décide de de passer à l'action
alors là dans le cas de l'ukraine c'est
effectivement assez frappant parce
qu'effectivement comme comme ça a été
dit à l'instant c'est un peu un
patchwork de différentes origines on va
dire mais la face à face à cette
agression aussi soudaine voilà il ya eu
un grand mouvement de solidarité et puis
quand même le passé de l'ukraine fait
que ce n'est pas la première fois que
les ukrainiens honte à se battre y
compris pour leur survie info rappeler
qu'ils ont combattu quand même les
soviétiques pendant pendant 12 ans et
donc ça a été très dur y compris pour
les soviétiques à l'époque yé-yé les
combats avec les nazis enfin bon et puis
il ya eu quand même aussi dans ces
périodes de crise extrême je pense le
rôle du du président zelensky qui a su
galvaniser
son peuple parce que dans une période
comme ça quand on a un dirigeant qui
fuit on lui a proposé d'ailleurs de fuir
les français ont proposé de l'accueillir
à l'ambassade de france et américains
ont proposé l'ex fils prêts donc il a su
en tout cas incarner et rencontrer en
fait sont je pense son peuple dans cette
période assez dure il ya d'autres
figures comme le maire de kiev 1 vitali
klischko bref
un peuple qui a été effectivement sidéré
mais qui a une histoire où il a dû se
battre et qui là est en train de se
mettre ça c'est sans doute pas du tout
l'objectif que cherchez vous l'a dit me
routine ce qui passe sa vie à dire c'est
un pays frère enfin il est en train de
porter la détestation vis-à-vis de la
russie à un niveau je pense jamais à
temps en ukraine et à développer très
fortement plus que jamais je dirais le
sentiment national ukrainien